um hello everyone I'm gonna play a nice
game on leeches and see uh What uh we
can what we can learn from this uh
obviously uh this will not be a high
caliber game like you guys are used to
seeing on this channel as I'm playing
not uh not a very strong player uh but I
will do my best not to be terrible and
also it might be even an incentive for
myself to improve a little bit so I'm
playing the queen D6 Scandinavian uh and
obviously my opponent still is deciding
between kingside and queen side castling
and he decides for kingside castles okay
so he played a bit of a pass passive
line not going for for D4 when he could
have he went for this D3 setup and I'm
pretty sure he wants to get those uh B4
B5 moves of the board and I have to beat
faster than him so I have no idea where
my king is going uh probably
Queen side but uh will still we'll still
see uh
yeah okay let's capture here
okay so not the really the game I wanted
to play but
uh seems like it's not going to be some
sort of a crazy attacking game it's
gonna be or it could be like he could
probably he will decline the queen trade
I would
yeah of course
uh let's push let's push he might even
bring the rookie okay he I thought he'd
bring the rook in first uh and then it
would be maybe a more interesting game
okay let's capture
um
Castle Queen side obviously
and now we push here I think he allowed
a bit too much here
uh so not really not really worried
about anything
uh yeah let's get those pawns out the
board
ah let's push H5
um oh okay B4 is coming of course
um at some point
at some point
can I even consider Bishop captures
followed by Knight to D4 do I have now
his Knight is too good of a Defender
here
but maybe it can be done maybe it can be
done let's try it
I I love the B4 move you guys know I
love the B4 move but let's try it
I would be very sad to see that B4 was
actually a blunder here because it
allowed this uh because it allowed this
move
um but let's see
let's see if it can be done now what was
my plan that's the question
my plan was an obvious one Rook captures
on G2 that was my plan it wasn't I only
thought of that now and I'm only kidding
uh and now of course we go here
so that was the plan
he can block with the Knight but uh
okay we're gonna take that with the
check
and we can even go a nice Queen G4 here
uh he does have two Rooks and the bishop
of course for my queen but uh the
problem is I have I have pawns here
so could be could be a bit of an issue
for him
yeah and uh he still has to connect his
uh
his pieces let's go here he can't take
now because of captures yeah he has to
move and now we're gonna take
wow this feels like a feels like a very
silly game
I don't even feel like I've accomplished
anything here
crazy
and he has more time
yeah once he once he fixes the position
of his Bishop uh he's gonna be he's
gonna be better
okay so this is how he's gonna do it
uh let's push that pawn let's push that
pawn
wow this is a this is in fact a terrible
game uh but I will check I'm very
interested in the evil okay now he's
just making silly moves
I have no idea why he did that
um
yeah let's go a nice check here
okay
we're completely winning now but uh you
know he had uh
he definitely had a win there
um
I'm trying to take something with Tempo
and then maybe even you know connect
with the Rook nicely but he's not
allowing it
it's very very sneaky about it
yeah okay we can't do it but uh
it doesn't really matter
thank you
still has some counter play I don't
believe in his counter play but he can
still defend
um
[Music]
all right now we push the pawn
okay of course he wants to cover that
square let's push
there we go
put the Rook behind the pawn and push
he's gonna push here
we're gonna push here
is this winning I can give up the queen
and then win his rook and then the two
pawns will beat the bishop in 14 seconds
I guess so
he actually found the beautiful way to
trick me
beautiful way to trick me
this is a very sad very sad
he is of course trying to flag me
and I will have to do everything I can
not to allow him that
okay I tricked him I tricked him I dirty
flagged him and in the end I won this
was uh this was this was a disgusting
game but I am interested just uh in that
position where did I go wrong
all right so I'm pretty sure this is all
fine yeah this is all the engine says
it's fine fine fine fine fine
uh okay G5 maybe a bit over ambitious
but still okay it's pretty much zero
zero we capture uh I allow the queen
trade but yeah okay Knight F5 okay let's
say F4 yeah everything is fine here G4
ah okay he wants to G4 right away okay I
mean still I mean I don't I don't expect
to play every every move uh of course in
a three minute game uh and now F3 is a
blunder sort of because of Bishop D7
video okay I'm still winning here
winning here G4 I'm winning here uh yeah
looks like I've played everything okay
okay and obviously Bishop captures on B7
on B4 I was a bit over ambitious but uh
yeah I actually just continue playing
normal moves and it's perfectly fine uh
but yeah here I I just couldn't resist
Knight to D4 Queen F2 and now Queen C4
okay captures Knight captures
G2 absolutely disgusting yeah and okay
now he should have captured with with
the King he played Queen captures now
Rook G8 uh captures captures uh and now
yeah sort of a
I I either draw or he will be pushing
for the win if he doesn't mess something
up
so yeah he's completely winning here
plus seven plus three plus four plus
three
yeah this was uh
wow I don't uh okay but now we're
actually winning here because uh of the
queen but I allowed him to push that
pass Pawn a bit too too far away about I
mean what you're going to have a few
seconds on the clock yeah this is now a
dead draw
uh again completely winning for him now
completely winning for him now it's a
draw and now
here I managed to trick him he wanted to
flag me and in doing so I knew that he
would of course Overlook his Queen uh it
was only a matter of when to do it like
I know that he's gonna try and check me
like six or seven times but that one
time he has to do some other move and
then I get a
a chance to to trick him like this like
uh like an absolutely disgusting person
uh but yeah there there you go we did it
I know what I did wrong uh you know I I
just couldn't resist not taking gun
before I'm sorry and on G2 so there you
have it uh see you soon